So why don't we get started? So, I'm Omer Yilmaz.
I'm a faculty member at the Koch Institute for Integrative Cancer Research, where
my lab studies the effects of diet on stem cells in
regeneration and colorectal cancer formation.
And I'm also a gastrointestinal pathologist at the Beth Israel Deaconess
Medical Center in Boston. And it's really a pleasure to chair
today's session. We have a lineup of great speakers in
Dr. Ruth Langley and Dr. Raymond
Dubois.
So today we'll talk about aspirin for the prevention and
treatment of colorectal cancer, and this is
a special session,
in addition, because it honors
the work and memory of Thomas Kensler, who
was a pioneer in cancer chemoprevention, whose work bridged mechanistic
toxicology and population-based clinical
studies.
And Tom, in addition to playing an important
role in helping establish this field,
he trained many of the individuals who went on to further
develop the field. And he was a devoted mentor
to generations of cancer prevention scientists, the achievement of
which he was most proud of. So again, this session is dedicated to
his memory, and I'd just like to call out to Dr.
Nancy Davidson,
Tom's wife. And Nancy, thank you so much for being here
today.
So
decades of evidence across study designs converge on
the same finding, which
is aspirin lowers colorectal cancer incidence and
mortality.
And aspirin is one of the best supported, studied
chemopreventive agents in oncology, which makes
understanding its mechanism and its limitations important.
And we've known for
more than two decades, in the Rothwell pooled meta-analysis, for example, when
aspirin is regularly taken by individuals at
the age of 60, that aspirin reduces
colorectal incidents on the order of 40%
and colorectal cancer mortality by greater than
50%. And this mean age of enrollment of 60 is important
because I'm going to, in my own presentation, talk
about an interesting paradox that occurs when aspirin
is started later in life, namely in patients that
average 70 years of age. And aspirin mediates
its many effects with respect to suppressing colorectal
cancer through multiple mechanisms.
And it's believed that aspirin, by suppressing prostaglandin
E2 in epithelial cells, as well as in adjacent niche
cells such as immune cells and in platelets, plays a key role in
regulating both the initiation and aspects of colorectal
cancer progression and metastasis.
In addition to a lot of the
patient
clinical trial data, we've known for more than 20 years that in
preclinical models such as in the ApcMin model,
which is a preclinical model for familial adenomatous polyposis, where
these mice,
within a few months of life, develop multiple adenomas.
When one deletes the gene prostaglandin synthase 1, or
COX-1, or prostaglandin synthase 2, COX-2, in this
preclinical model, one dramatically dampens adenoma
formation throughout the small intestine and colon.
And
one of our speakers today, Dr.
Raymond Dubois, has really been a leader in understanding how
prostaglandins early on in the intestinal and colonic
epithelium, how prostaglandins mediate this by binding to
their receptor and engaging pathways that are important
for survival, proliferation, invasion,
angiogenesis, and other
mechanisms. And I look forward to Ray's talk
later this morning. In addition to being
a potent suppressor of early dysplasia in the
colon,
aspirin can also play an important role in colorectal progression.
So work from Andy Chan, Charlie Fuchs, and
Shuji Ojino have demonstrated
that PIK3CA mutations in exon 9 and exon
20 can serve as a biomarker of response for aspirin.
When aspirin is started early on after diagnosis,
aspirin use suppresses or decreases the probability of death
from colorectal cancer in patients that harbor these
mutations compared to colorectal cancers
that are wild type in PIK3CA
mutations. And Dr. Ruth Langley will talk
more about this in her session after mine.
So I'd like to end my introduction with a bit of
more controversial or paradoxical data.
Which is, I mentioned to you in the Rothwell pooled randomized
control trial that when aspirin is started in
patients that are on average 60 years of age and taken
regularly, that leads to a reduction in colorectal cancer
incidence and mortality. In the ASPREE trial, on average,
patients
with an average age of 70 who regularly took aspirin,
interestingly, these patients, within a short period of four years, started to
diverge from their placebo group, where there was an increase in death
related to cancer. So why is that?
This really raises a paradox that I'd like to explore in my
presentation, which is, does aspirin have opposing effects on cancer
initiation versus metastasis?And the work
that I'm going to talk about today is unpublished.
Actually, it's the first time that I'm talking about it, so I apologize if it's a
bit rough around the edges. But it's about understanding the
paradoxical effect of aspirin on colorectal cancer prevention and
metastasis. The work was led by a very talented
MD-PhD student in my lab, Joseph Sedlock, in
collaboration with Dr. Swagata Goswami and
Burak Yildiz. And this was a collaboration between my lab and Andrew
Chan's lab at the Mass General Hospital.
So, my disclosures per ACR
rules.
So what do we know about aspirin and cancer
metastasis? So work published last year by
Yang et al. in "Nature,"
proposed that aspirin reduces metastatic initiation and seeding
by limiting platelet-derived thromboxane A2, which
inhibits T cell function. And
we like to think about metastasis as having many phases, but two important
phases of metastasis are seeding of a distant organ
and then the outgrowth of those seeds into established
metastatic lesions. And what Yang and colleagues showed
last year using a B16 melanoma lung metastasis
model is that when these mice were given aspirin, this
reduced the number of micromets and nodules in the lung,
and that this
suppression could be rescued by treating these mice with a
thromboxane A2 analog. And mechanistically, they
propose that thromboxane A2 can
activate this protein in T cells called R-GEF1.
And using a genetic approach where they conditionally ablate
R-GEF1 in T cells of mice, this
essentially nullifies the effects of aspirin and
thromboxane A2 on metastasis. So this was
important insight regarding a potential suppressive role that
aspirin plays in the early steps of metastatic seeding to
the lung. But what about
aspirin's effects on established metastases, that is
metastatic outgrowth? So coming back to the ASPREE
trial where aspirin used in 70-year-old
individuals over time increases cancer mortality.
Again, notice that these curves start to diverge between aspirin and placebo
at about four years, which is really too rapid for new
cancer initiation and spread throughout the body.
It's more consistent with the possibility that
aspirin use may be accelerating the outgrowth of preexisting
occult metastatic disease.
So why was this trial such an outlier?
Does aspirin promote the growth of preexisting
micrometastases? So if one digs into the data from
McNeill and colleagues from ASPREE, one finds that
aspirin appears to promote metastasis across multiple cancer
types in ASPREE. While there wasn't a notable
effect in Stage 1 through 3, in Stage 4, where there's metastatic
disease, aspirin
accelerated
cancer death in these patients.
So what happens to patients with colorectal cancer in ASPREE on
aspirin after their diagnoses? So in unpublished work
by
Andy Chan's group at the MGH, they find that in colorectal
cancer patients with Stage 1 to 3 disease, there's a
trend towards aspirin actually
improving overall survival. But interestingly, in Stage
4 colorectal cancer patients, aspirin increases overall
mortality by greater than twofold, suggesting that aspirin's
effect on mortality after colorectal cancer diagnosis
is stage dependent. So again, this really sets up
our aspirin paradox for colorectal cancer, where there's a
lot of preclinical and patient data suggesting that
aspirin in young or middle adulthood
suppresses colorectal cancer incidence and improves
overall mortality rates. But aspirin also increases
colorectal cancer mortality in those patients with Stage 4
metastatic disease. How can one reconcile these
paradoxical findings?
So, this really leads into my lab's expertise, where we have a lot of
expertise in modeling physiologic metastasis
in colorectal cancer, where we can take patient-derived or
mouse-derived organoids, these are primary cells,
and then we can engineer in cancer-causing mutations in the
tumor suppressor genes, APC, p53, and the
proto-oncogene K-RAS. This genotype of
APC-K-RAS-p53, I'm going to call by short
AKP. And this AKP genotype in colorectal cancer
is found in up to 50% of colon cancer
patients. And then we can really interrogate metastasis by
performing two types of transplantation assays.
In the first
assay, we can transplant these AKT colorectal cancer
organoids into the colon of recipient mice.
After a few weeks, these mice not only develop primary
tumors in the colon, but a subset of these mice go on to develop
metastatic disease in the liver, the primary site of
metastasis for colon cancer.
In parallel to this type of orthotopic transplantation system,
we can also transplant these AKP colorectal cancer organoids
in equal cell numbers into the portal circulation, which is the
vasculature that empties into the liver.
And this model allows us to assay metastasis
directly, where initiation of these metastatic lesions is
essentially a measure of metastatic establishment
and outgrowth.So what do we find? So when we
transplant these AKP organoids into the colon of mice and then
perform transcriptional analysis on the metastatic lesions
relative to their primary counterparts, one interesting
observation that we made is that the metastatic lesions
downregulate prostaglandin synthase 1, a key enzyme in
the production of prostaglandin E2.
And not only does one see downregulation of prostaglandin E2,
but when one measures prostaglandin E2 in organoids derived
from these metastatic lesions versus
organoids from the primary site, again, one finds that the metastatic
organoids are less capable of generating prostaglandin
E2 compared to the control primary.
Again, consistent with the trends that we're observing in our
gene changes in PTGS1. But
one could ask, is this some type of idiosyncrasy of the mouse model we're using?
Is it generalizable to patients? To gain insight
into this, we analyzed patients with matched primary
colorectal cancer and liver metastases where RNA
sequencing was performed. And again, analogous to what
we observed in our mouse AKP model, we find that
PTGS1 was downregulated in the liver met compared
to the primary tumor, and no change in
PTGS2. Again, consistent with what we were observing in our mouse
model.
So this then leads to the question: Does prostaglandin
E2 play a functional role in colorectal cancer
metastasis?
And again, we took advantage of our genome editing toolbox where
we could manipulate prostaglandin E2 levels
genetically in our AKP organoids.
So we generated organoids that were deficient in prostaglandin
synthase 1 and 2, and this corresponds to a reduction in
PGE2 in data that I'm not showing you.
And then conversely, we can delete the gene
HPGD, which codes for 15-prostaglandin
dehydrogenase, an enzyme that degrades prostaglandin E2.
Thus, loss of HPGD leads to an increase in
prostaglandin E2, which we were able to verify in organoid
assays. So now that we have a toolkit where we can genetically
manipulate prostaglandin E2 levels, specifically
in tumor cells, we can ask the question: What are the effects of
colorectal cancer-produced prostaglandins in the two
metastasis models that I described to you?
So in the first set of transplantations, we transplanted
AKP or AKP PTGS1,2
deficient organoids, which again are low in prostaglandin
E2 levels. In terms of primary colon
growth, we found no change in greatest
dimension or in mass of these primary tumors.
But interestingly, when we looked at metastasis, we observed,
again, consistent with what Yang et al.
published last year, that dampening prostaglandin E2 in the
primary tumor resulted in fewer
metastatic lesions,
in this case, in the liver, where the control AKP gave
rise to many more mets per recipient
compared to the AKP COX-1, COX-2 deficient
organoids. But it's not that none of the
PTGS1,2 deficient organoids
didn't give rise to mets. Clearly, some animals developed
metastatic lesions in the liver. So we then wanted to analyze
what effect loss of PTGS1 within the hepatic
parenchyma had on metastatic outgrowth.
And
I should just mention that our AKP organoids also harbor
a tdTomato fluorescent marker that permits us to carefully
identify and measure the size of these lesions.
So here we're looking at the livers from mice that received AKP or
AKP PTGS1,2 deficient organoids.
So the AKP recipients had more
metastatic lesions, but that tended to be much smaller in
size compared to the hepatic parenchyma that
received PTGS1,2 deficient AKP organoids.
And here we're looking at the size of these organoids on a log10 plot,
and these PTGS1,2 deficient
cancer cells were about tenfold greater in size in the
liver compared to their control counterparts.
So does aspirin treatment mimic the effects
of genetically ablating PTGS1,2 in these AKP
organoids? So again, we transplanted AKP and
AKP PTGS1,2 deficient organoids into the
colon and now treated these mice with equivalents of low-dose
aspirin. And just focusing on here where we're looking at
primary tumor prostaglandin E2, again,
consistent with genetic ablation of PTGS1,2,
aspirin treatment reduces primary tumor PGE2 levels.
And again, if we now look at metastatic outgrowth in the liver in the
subsets of mice that develop metastatic disease, consistent with
genetic loss, aspirin treatment also increased the
size of these metastatic lesions in the liver,
indicating that aspirin increases the size of colorectal
cancer liver metastases. So what happens
if one bypasses the primary tumor and now places equivalent
numbers of colorectal cancer cells directly into the portal
circulation to seed the liver? So here we
transplanted AKP and our AKP
PTGS1,2 deficient organoids. And what we
now find is that
downregulation of PGE2 reduces the number and
size of these metastatic lesions, and
loss of PTGS1,2 dramatically increases the numbers and
sizeAgain, here we've quantified numbers of liver mets,
which is analogous to what we find if we were to measure size, that there's a
notable increase in the size and numbers of
metastatic lesions in the liver when we place these PTGS1-2
deficient AKP organoids into the portal circulation.
So the fact that prostaglandins seem to inhibit metastatic
outgrowth raised the possibility that perhaps
prostaglandins themselves can treat colorectal cancer
liver mets in patients that harbor potentially
micrometastatic lesions. To address this, we took advantage of
the other set of organoids that we engineered in the lab, the AKP and
AKPHPGD deficient organoids. Remember,
these organoids are high in PGE2
levels. And when we transplant these into the portal circulation,
consistent with the notion that prostaglandins inhibit metastatic
outgrowth, we find that these
HPGD deficient organoids give rise to fewer and
smaller metastatic lesions in the
liver. In addition to taking a genetic approach, we also took a
pharmacological approach where we treated these
recipient mice with a 15 prostaglandin dehydrogenase
inhibitor, this molecule called
SW033291. So here we
transplanted AKP organoids into the portal circulation,
treated these mice with the 15 PGDH
inhibitor. And what we found here, analogous to the
AKPHPGD deficient organoids, is that treatment with this
antagonist
reduced the number and size of these organoids.
And here's just representative images from one of these
recipients from each group, where in the vehicle treatment, one has greater numbers
of organoids that are larger in size, and treatment with the
inhibitor reduces number and size of these metastatic
lesions. So what is the mechanism by which prostaglandin
is mediating these anti-metastatic outgrowth effects in the
liver? Could there be a role for the immune system in this process, given the
interesting findings from Yang et al. last year?
So
we wanted to turn our attention to T cells and
NK cells, given the important role that these populations play
in cancer immunology. So in data that I've shown you, we repeated our
transplantation where we transplanted AKP and
AKPPTGS12 deficient organoids.
Again, these are low in prostaglandins.
And in immunocompetent recipients, which have a normal
immune system that's syngeneic with the organoids that we're transplanting,
we find that PTGS12, when
transplanted into the portal circulation, increases the number and size
of these metastatic lesions. But now what happens when one
transplants these organoids into mice that lack a
functional immune system? In this case, we use NOD/SCID gamma mice, which
have dysfunctional T, B, and NK cells.
And in this recipient model, where adaptive
immune cells as well as NK cells are compromised, now this difference
between the seeding of the liver disappears, indicating that
likely one of these immune cell populations is an important mediator
of the anti-metastatic outgrowth effects of
prostaglandin. So which population is at play here?
So we went ahead and depleted either CD8
positive T cells with antibodies or NK cells with
antibodies. And we transplanted in our AKP and
AKPHPGDH
deficient organoids, which again are high in prostaglandin and which should have an
inhibitory effect on metastatic seeding and outgrowth when
injected into the portal circulation.
And what we found here is when we depleted CD8 positive T cells,
again, the HPGD compared to the control were less
capable of forming these metastatic lesions.
Depletion of CD8 positive T cells trended but
didn't significantly impact these effects of tumor-derived
prostaglandin. What happens when one now depletes the
NK cells? When we deplete NK cells and now repeat these
transplantations, we now find that depletion of NK cells
really prevents the inhibitory effects that tumor-derived
prostaglandins have on establishing
and enabling metastatic outgrowth.
So how do prostaglandins trigger NK cell-mediated anti-tumor
immunity? We turned our attention to the tumor microenvironment.
And we were really interested in this particular component
of the liver microenvironment called these hepatic stellate cells or
HSCs, because a lot is known about these HSCs, and they play an important
role in regulating the immune milieu in the
liver. The other reason why we were interested in studying HSCs is
because we knew from spatial transcriptomics data, where we
performed spatial transcriptomics in mice that were
transplanted with AKP organoids and treated with our 15
prostaglandin synthase inhibitor, the SW molecule, that
compared to vehicle treated where we have large metastatic lesions,
shown here in green, with many hepatic stellate cells, shown here in
yellow, when we treat with our... our
15-PGDH inhibitor, now the metastases
shrink, and we have fewer HSCs. And we can validate
that this reduction in HSCs doesn't only occur at the transcriptional
level. If we use flow cytometry to enumerate these HSCs, again,
we find that after treatment with our inhibitor, there's a notable
several-fold reduction in the percentage of HSCs in this liver.
So this really indicated that perhaps these
HSCs might be mediating some of the anti-tumor
immunity effects of tumor-derived prostaglandins.
So do HSCs mediate these effects of PG2 in
colorectal cancer metastasis? To address this, we generated a
mouse model that enabled us to selectively
deplete HSCs in the liver parenchyma.
So here we're staining with a marker of these HSCs, shown here in red.
So in the control liver, HSCs are quite abundant and spaced out
throughout the hepatic lobule. And in our diphtheria toxin model, where
we can selectively deplete these HSCs, we see a
nice reduction of HSCs.
So what happens now if we transplant our AKP
organoids into livers that lack these HSCs?
So here we transplanted again our AKP and AKPH
PGD-deficient organoids, which loss of HPGD
leads to high prostaglandins, which suppresses metastatic outgrowth.
When we now ablate HSCs, we nullify the
inhibitory effects that prostaglandins have on metastatic
outgrowth. So I'd just like to summarize and say that
aspirin reduces prostaglandin E2 in liver mets by driving
metastatic outgrowth through what we propose is this
HSC NK cell circuit. We think this is an important step
in resolving the aspirin paradox, where the evidence
is clear. Aspirin chemoprevention reduces
PG2-mediated tumor initiation in the colon.
And in the liver,
in response to metastatic seeding, by reducing PG2
in the liver, aspirin permits micrometastatic outgrowth via
HSC-mediated NK suppression,
a potential mechanism in the elderly that may have higher rates of
micrometastatic occult disease.
So we're proposing that prostaglandin from micromets
are suppressing hepatic stellate cells, which are known to make
chemokines such as CXCL12 that are known to suppress
NK cell biology, where NK cells themselves can
then inhibit
micrometastatic outgrowth. And we're
now currently working on trying to understand how
CXCL12 is doing this, and could there be other HSC-derived
factors that are contributing to these suppressive effects of
HSCs. So with that, I'd just like to thank the members of our
laboratory, including our collaborators Andy Chan, David
Drew at the Mass General, and I think we have three minutes for questions.
So for questions for all the sessions, feel free to
please use the microphones
if possible.
Hi, John Burn, Newcastle. That was amazing, and I
imagine like the rest of the audience, I'm struggling to fully absorb it.
But it does make sense. It clearly explains the paradox that you referred
to.
The other dimension that I struggle with is the
question of apoptosis and where that plays in all of this.
And I just wonder whether-- And we know from the work of my colleagues
in Newcastle that knocking out mitochondrial function allows tumors to
progress, and that
there is a logical argument, since salicylates promote apoptosis
in plants, that they may well play a similar role in humans.
So my simple question is, is that an aspect that you have been able to
look at in terms of apoptotic bodies, and does that play into this story
as well as part of what you've just been
describing?
I think there could be many
contributors to the phenotype that I described.
We think anti-cancer immunity is one role for
prostaglandins in micromets. It'd be interesting to see,
and we haven't done this experiment, we should do it, how loss of prostaglandin
E2 or elevation of prostaglandin E2
stimulates the growth of these micromets directly by looking at
proliferation, et cetera. Whether it's a causal or it's
occurring through HSCs and NK cells is
something that we would need to test, but we have the mouse models to test this.
Clearly in the primary tumor, work done by Ray and many others have shown that
prostaglandins stimulate proliferation,
have
pro-survival benefit. In micromets,
where it's a new environment for these cancer cells, it need not be the
case, but it could be. We need to really dissect that out in our liver
models where we can manipulate the components of HSCs,
NK cells, and CD8 positive T cells.
Great, thank you.
Hi, I'm Sandy Markowitz from Cleveland.
Our lab developed SW33291.
Just a comment that even at the initiation stage,
the effects of PG2 are incredibly context dependent.
So while it's absolutely true that Ray showed many years
ago that administering PG2 to the APC
mouse will accelerate tumor formation,
we presented data last year that in the AOM DSS
model, PG2 actually again reduces tumor formation.
SoWhether that is immune dependent or
not is unclear. But what is clear is that there are so
many different pathways downstream of both
COX-2 and PGDH,
that you can get different outcomes depending on the context of which you
tune the model.
No, and I agree. And I think the liver, at least
in the state that we're
studying it in, in the non-inflamed liver, it'd be interesting to look in fatty
livers,
in the alcohol-damaged liver, we may come to different conclusions.
But
it's something to keep in mind. Thank you so much for the comment.
Thanks for the very elegant work.
So I think I see the red light flashing, so I think that
indicates that I'm out of time, but I am the chair, so
I do have a responsibility to introduce and moderate.
So our next speaker is Professor Ruth
Langley from the University College of London, who's a physician
scientist and has played many important
roles in elucidating a lot of the
translational aspects of aspirin
treatment in patients. Ruth, welcome to the
podium.
Good morning, and thank you for the introduction.
I'm going to talk about platelet activation and inhibition
and its relationship to aspirin and cancer prevention.
These are my disclosures. I've received grant funding from Cancer
Research UK for aspirin-related work, and the
AdAspirin trial has received donated aspirin and placebo from
Bayer.
The history of aspirin and cancer, as we've heard,
dates back many years. This is one of the first
studies that was published in The Lancet over 50 years
ago. It's a relatively simple experiment
where cancer cells were injected into mice and half the
mice were given aspirin in their drinking water.
Those that received aspirin developed significantly
fewer lung metastases, and I think if this was published
today with a new drug, it would generate a lot of
interest.
This was then followed by many epidemiological
studies looking at aspirin for primary
prevention.
This is some summary data that was put together
around 2020. Over 200
studies, both case control and cohort
studies.
The key findings were the aspirin reduces the risk
of colorectal cancer and other GI cancers
by about 30%.
The estimates for other tumor types were around
10% or more uncertain.
But the key thing to note from these studies is that they were
all evaluating low dose,
somewhere between 75 and 325 milligrams
of aspirin daily, and that's an antiplatelet
dose rather than an anti-inflammatory dose,
where you have to give the aspirin three or four times a day.
The challenges, as we've just heard, are that the
clinical trial results have been variable.
There is good evidence that aspirin prevents
Lynch syndrome cancers through the CAP-2 and
CAP-3 trials, which were led by Professor Sir
John Burn, which we heard about in the symposium
yesterday.
And importantly, the CAP-3 trial has
shown that 100 milligrams of aspirin daily
is as effective as 600 milligrams for
preventing these tumors.
But in the non-molecularly selected populations,
such as the ASPREE trial, the results have not
always been what we have expected.
The effect of aspirin on the arachidonic pathway is well
characterized as shown by the diagram, and this
work has come both from the cancer field
and from the cardiovascular field.
Low dose daily aspirin inhibits COX-1,
and the clinical effect is most marked in the
anucleate platelet that can't resynthesize
COX-1 and the effect lasts for the
duration of the platelet life, which is about 10 days.
You get subsequent reductions in prostaglandins and
thromboxane A2,
but again, as we've just heard, how that precisely
links to cancer prevention has been less clear.
And that got us to thinking about precision
medicine and aspirin and cancer
prevention. When we normally think about precision
medicine, we think we start with
enhanced knowledge of cancer biology, and we think that
this will lead to a new or repurposed drug development
program, ideally with a companion
biomarker, and that will allow us to identify the
individuals that are most likely to benefit and
improved
outcomes.When we put
aspirin into this schema, we already have the drug.
It's widely available and pretty well-tolerated.
We also have substantial epidemiological
evidence and some randomized evidence of
improved outcomes.
But there are several unanswered questions, particularly
how does aspirin prevent cancer, and how can we
identify those individuals most likely to benefit?
And it was these questions that led us to
forming what we've called the SPARC collaboration, and it's a
collection of basic scientists, clinicians, patient
advocates, pharmacologists, and trialists
all working together, and I'm going to show you some of their
work
in the next slides.
So I'm going to start with the mechanism of action.
And I'm going to focus on two studies.
The first one is work from the lab of
Paola Patrigiani in the University of Chieti,
and they were working with mice that have a specific deletion
of the COX-1 gene in megakaryocytes and
platelets, so they're a good model of low dose
daily aspirin.
And they crossed these mice with ApcMin mice,
and what they found is the progeny developed fewer
and smaller adenomas, highlighting
the importance of platelet COX-1 activity in
early carcinogenesis. What was also
interesting about this study was that the adenomas that did
develop had less COX-2, suggesting that
COX-1 expression drives COX-2 induction in
this model.
And this also potentially explains how both
low dose aspirin and selective COX-2
inhibitors in clinical trials have been shown to
prevent adenoma formation.
The second study I want to focus on is the study
that was previously mentioned from the laboratory of Rahul
Roy Chowdhury at the University of Cambridge and
published in "Nature" last year.
This story starts from an in vivo mouse
genetic screen, which was aimed at
identifying the host regulators of cancer
metastasis.
The group was focused on RGF1 in T
cells, which inhibits T cell immunity, and what they
found was that it was regulated by the thromboxane
receptor, which was an unexpected finding.
And the reason that this was exciting was it linked for the
first time the known pharmacological effects of
once daily low dose aspirin, particularly reducing
thromboxane A2 and cancer clearance.
And it also, for the first time, implicated aspirin
in a potential immune mechanism.
So putting these two studies together, we have the
hypothesis that the anticancer effects of
aspirin are mediated and
started through a reduction
in platelet activation, and particularly the lowering
of thromboxane A2.
For primary prevention, there's a link between
COX-1 and COX-2 in the inflammatory
pathways, and for metastasis, the
immune system is now implicated.
So this led us to thinking, could platelet activation
be a marker that we could use to find out who would
benefit most from aspirin?
Now you can measure platelet activation through a stable
urinary metabolite of thromboxane A2,
11-dehydro thromboxane B2, which is
also known as UTXM.
It's been studied extensively in cardiovascular disease,
and you can see from the slide that it's raised in certain
cardiovascular conditions, but it's also
raised in
and associated with cancer risk factors, for
example, having a high BMI,
diabetes, or in smokers.
The ADD-ASPIRIN trial is a phase three basket
trial. It's an ongoing adjuvant trial
assessing aspirin after radical treatment,
and the protocol includes four
individually powered phase three trials in four different
tumor types, one in breast cancer,
colorectal cancer, gastroesophageal cancer,
and prostate cancer.
It's recruited over 10,000 participants from three
different countries.
The protocol also contains a run-in phase
where everyone takes aspirin 100 milligrams
daily for eight weeks to see if they tolerate
aspirin and to see if they want to continue in the trial.
If they do so, they are then randomized to taking aspirin
100 milligrams, aspirin 300 milligrams,
or a placebo for at least five
years.And that framework has allowed
us to study platelet activation at trial entry,
after the run-in phase, and also during the randomization
phase.
So in this sub-study, which
contains 700 participants from the ADD-Aspirin
trial,
we first were able to show that the
UTXM levels were higher at baseline than
healthy individuals. In the graph, the dotted
line, which you can see at the bottom, is the levels that we would
expect for healthy individuals based on previous studies.
And this was a surprise because these were adjuvant patients
who we
are assuming are clear of their disease
at trial entry.
The other unexpected finding was that we saw a
difference between the tumor types.
So we found higher levels in the patients that had
colorectal cancer and gastroesophageal
cancer compared to breast cancer and prostate
cancer. And that's an interesting observation given
the higher levels in the tumors that arise from the
GI tract, given the epidemiological data that
I showed you earlier.
We then went on to do multivariate analysis, and what we
found was that the higher UTXM levels in the
patients with the GI tumors could not be accounted
for by recent surgery, chemotherapy, or
any other clinical factor.
And reassuringly, within this study, we found that
the higher UTXM levels were associated with
higher BMI, smoking, and raised
inflammatory
markers as we would expect.
We also measured the UTXM levels over
time and by randomized group. And in
these plots, the blue line
represents UTXM levels at baseline.
The red line, where you can see it's suppressed in all the three
plots, is at the end of the run-in, where everyone has been
taking aspirin. And then we have the green line,
which reflects the randomization phase.
And if you look in the group that received placebo, you can see
that the line has come up again in that placebo
group, indicating persistent platelet
activation in those recently diagnosed with
cancer.
Other groups have looked at UTXM levels
and cancer outcomes. This is just one
example. It's from the Framingham Heart Study.
Here they had over 3,000 participants,
and what they found were that there were higher UTXM levels at
baseline were associated with reduced
survival, the blue line on the graph.
And what was interesting is this association was
not just for all-cause mortality or
cardiovascular mortality as you might expect, but it
was also associated with cancer mortality.
And there was an interesting editorial that
accompanied this paper, which was entitled "Less
Thromboxane, Longer Life."
What has emerged recently is that in
colorectal cancer, is that PIK3CA
mutation status
appears to be a biomarker of aspirin response.
And this is data that you saw in the previous talk.
It dates back to 2012. It's
epidemiological data, and it was looking at aspirin
use after a colorectal cancer diagnosis.
And what was found that the improved colorectal
cancer-specific survival and overall survival
was seen with aspirin if the tumor had a
mutation in the PIK3CA exon 9 and 20,
but not if the tumor was wild type.
This data and several other pieces of data
led to several groups across the globe
setting up adjuvant aspirin trials,
particularly in colorectal cancer.
I'm just going to orientate you on this slide.
We have time across the bottom. Each of the solid
blocks represents a phase III randomized
trial with the follow-up period, and then the small
square when we're expecting results.
As you can see,
we've color-coded this for two different types of
trials. The ones in red are those that
recruited patients that specifically had a mutation in the
PIK3CA pathway,
and the ones in blue are molecularly unselected, so
that they recruited all comers. And I'm just going to show you
some of the results that have emerged from this group.
So the first result came from the ASCULT trial.
This was a large trial, over 1,500 patients
with either a Dukes B or a Dukes C carcinoma
of the colon or rectum.And they
evaluated aspirin 200 milligrams daily
versus placebo.
You can see that they were unable to show a significant
result on either disease-free survival, which was their primary
outcome measure, or overall survival.
This contrasts with the Alaska trial, which was published
last year in the New England Journal of Medicine.
In this study from Scandinavia, they recruited
over 600 patients with either a
PIK3CA mutation in exons nine and 20,
which they call Group A, and also a second
group which had a somatic variant in the
PIK3 pathway, including PTEN,
which they call Group B.
Overall, these two groups accounted for nearly
40% of their colorectal population, and they
evaluated aspirin 160 milligrams
daily versus placebo.
And as you can see from the plots,
aspirin decreased the time to recurrence, which was their primary
outcome measure, and it also improved disease-free
survival by about 50%. And you can see
hazard ratios here of about 0.5. And this
has been a very significant result and is already being
incorporated into some clinical
guidelines.
So in summary,
low dose daily aspirin inhibits platelet
activation, which is linked to many
cancer-related pathways.
We know that many cancer risk factors, particularly
high BMI, diabetes, smoking, mutagens,
all activate platelets.
We've been able to demonstrate abnormal
and persistent platelet activation in adjuvant
cancer patients even up to six months
after they've finished their radical treatment.
PIK3CA mutations are clearly emerging as an important
biomarker for aspirin use in colorectal cancer.
And I think the future is for mechanistically
derived personalized approaches to the use of
aspirin and actually potentially other
antiplatelet drugs in cancer prevention.
And I would just like to finish by
thanking
my co-investigators within the
SPARC collaboration, particularly John Burn,
Carlo Patrono, Rahul Roy Chowdhury,
and Bianca Rocca, all of whom I
showed some of their data today. Thank you.
Hi, Ruth. Thank you so much
for a very clear presentation. Is there any connection--
the PIK3
connection to aspirin, I find that really interesting.
Is there any connection, do you think, to platelet activation?
Is there something unique about those tumors and
ongoing platelet activation that might be stimulating
thromboxane A2? Or
are there any insights into why those tumors respond so well?
I think you've highlighted really the key question.
There are a number of theories. I think one of the things
that's interesting is that PIK3CA mutations
act like a public neoantigen, and it may be that
they are just actually signaling a very immunogenic
kind of tumor, and therefore, that then links to the
immune system very nicely.
How platelet activation fits into that, I
think is where as a group, we're really trying to focus
now.
But we don't know the answer.
Thank you.
Hi.
A follow-up on Dr. Yilmaz's
presentation and the work that you've just presented.
Dr. Yilmaz
suggested
that the liver itself becomes more
immunogenic
in terms of greater activation of NK cells.
And I'm wondering if there's any epidemiologic data that would suggest that
aspirin would suppress liver mets in breast cancer,
another disease where you prominently see that malignant
phenotype.
Not that I'm aware of, but I think that the more
interesting findings and the new findings that are coming
out from the lab is going to make us go back
and look very carefully
at big
datasets to see what we can find.
I know that there's work which I alluded to at the end,
now thinking about the other antiplatelet drugs,
and I think we need to look at those, and we need to look in other
tumor types wider than colorectal cancer, and I
think people will do that.
Ruth, thank you so much. So our next speaker is Dr.
Raymond DuBois, Director of the Medical University
in South Carolina, Hollings Cancer Center, Associate Provost for
Cancer Programs, and a executive board
member of the Marks Foundation. And just a quick vignette,
I remember reading Ray's papers as a graduate student, even though I
was in a
different field, and that was 25 years ago.
So, Ray, welcome to the podium.
I'm definitely getting older, for sure.
I just want to have a call-out to Tom Kensler.
He and I were on several committees together.
He was a guiding voice in cancer prevention.
He really did some trials that
really set the way for looking at agents that
can cause cancer and how to intervene and reduce
that from happening. And we miss him, and he was
really a tremendous person in this field.
I'm glad we can dedicate this symposium to him.
Well, I'm going to talk about a lot of the work, and you've heard some of it
already, about targeting cyclooxygenase in colorectal
cancer.
And also, I'll mention a little bit about the PI3 kinase as well.
I really don't have anything to declare.
So did this word cloud thing. I really don't do these
usually, but it is
evolving now where cancer prevention has become
much more attention because of the early detection test,
measuring surrogate markers. The ACR did a survey
recently of all of the members and found that
the number one priority that was listed by early and late
investigators was
research on cancer prevention,
although that's not evident today by our audience.
But it is an area that's gaining a lot of interest.
So what I'm going to focus on today is some emerging concepts in
cancer prevention. Mention a little bit about the Precancer
Atlas.
We've looked at a lot of inflammatory mediators and how they may
affect
the cells in the tumor microenvironment.
And then this COX-2/PGE2, PI3 kinase
emerging theme, and then some potential new targets
for prevention or interception.
Now, this is a hypothetical diagram.
There's no data here. It's just sort of
globally looking at outcome of people with
early and late stage cancer globally.
So it's a value concept of early detection and intervention.
And Tim Rebbeck usually talks about this in his
presentations. So if you look at survival and
then the stage of diagnosis, pre-cancer or I, II, III,
IV,
patients tend to do a lot better when we pick the disease up
earlier. And as you've seen with the aspirin data, if you
intervene,
then you can affect the outcome, especially in the Lynch patients.
So,
this concept shows that it
can reduce the number of cancers, shift to an earlier curable
stage, and then improve overall survival at the population
level. So as we dial in these
blood tests for early precursors of cancer that we can
pick up in the bloodstream, I think this will become a lot more
available for our patients to try to detect these,
as early as possible and intervene.
And there are probably going to be lot of different ways, new imaging techniques,
and other things where we can follow this.
So, a little bit about the Precancer Atlas.
This was a Moonshot project, and
I chair one of the committees that oversees the
Precancer Atlas.
This was a Moonshot project that was funded to
systematically map the earliest cellular and molecular changes that
occur before cancer's fully developed.
And it has been fruitful. It identified early clonal
expansion, actually in normal tissues before they even become
cancer cells.
They found many normal tissues harbor driver
mutations that were actually oncogenes and other tumor
suppressor genes long before cancer develops in that tissue.
So this is a very interesting observation, and I think
at some point, hopefully, we'll understand why some of these go to cancer
and some don't, and then be able to modulate that.
They did extensive mapping of the microenvironment in
premalignancy.
And they're really working to try to distinguish high from low risk
lesions,
and develop new targets for interception, mostly in
inflammatory and immune evasion pathways.
But the project is still largely descriptive, but it
has really shown that this
normal to cancer is a continuum. It's not really a binary event with
one switch.
And so the clinical importance of this is still emerging.
Now, this is ancient history at this point, but I thought it might be good
to go back to how we initially got involved in this whole
project. Actually,
I had done my postdoc at Hopkins with Dan Nathans, and we were
in the process of cloningAll of the growth-related
genes and cells that we had in culture, mostly
fibroblasts.
And then when I moved to Vanderbilt for my first faculty
position,
we started studying these rat intestinal epithelial cells.
They were non-transformed. We could grow them easily in culture
and manipulate their growth status so that we could
either add growth factors or serum, and they were
dividing quite a bit, or we could make them
quiescent by removing the growth factors or serum.
We did a number of cloning experiments and were able to clone about
340 genes that were either up or down-regulated.
But
one of the things that I found surprising is this COX-2 gene was
really the most common
gene in these cells treated with EGF or
TGF-alpha,
and it was a multi-fold induction within a half an hour
that came back down to normal within 24 hours.
And then we looked at
colorectal cancers and adenomas.
We found
that COX-2 was expressed in about 85%
of colorectal cancers at a higher level than normal, and then
about 43% of adenomas, and mostly adenomas
greater than one centimeter in size, so then the larger adenomas.
So this, along with some other data I'll show, really piqued our
interest in looking into this pathway in terms of
colorectal cancer.
So,
the discovery of this gene really set off a
flurry of activity
by drug companies, and really the first
publication came out by Dan Simmons in April of
'91, where he was looking at SRC-activated
chicken embryo fibroblasts.
About the same time, Harvey Hershman at UCLA published
this phorbol ester-stimulated
cells, 3T3 cells, and published this in JBC.
I was in the process of moving from Baltimore to Nashville.
We had actually cloned this gene pretty early, but it wasn't
one that we were particularly interested in because it wasn't a transcription
factor. It wasn't really a signaling molecule that cancer
scientists usually study. But eventually, we did publish it
in '93.
This is just a lesson. Once you identify something that
nobody knows about, you try to publish that right away because then you get
more credit for it.
But the
drug companies really attacked this
molecule quite aggressively. GD Searle really
started this under the direction of Phil Needleman, and
they reported
a molecule, celecoxib, that could inhibit the enzyme
in '96. It was FDA approved for use in arthritis
by '98. So if you
look at
the usage of this drug now, there's about 10 million users in the US, and I
think studying that population is going to be interesting to see
if they do have an alteration in their cancer risk.
But going to translate a DNA sequence into a
drug in essentially seven or eight years is a
remarkable feat.
Merck also got into the process of doing this and
developed a drug called Vioxx or rofecoxib, and it was
FDA approved in '99, and again, this was a very rapid
translation. Vioxx was withdrawn from the market
on September 30th of 2004
because of its cardiovascular side effects.
And both of these drugs really were developed for pain and
osteoarthritis, and they're very effective for that purpose.
Celecoxib stayed on the market, and I'll show you some of the
safety data that was done later,
and again, it's widely used. There's
over 40 million people worldwide that are using it now,
so it's a very commonly used drug.
And at the proper dosages, it doesn't seem to have that much of a
cardiovascular problem.
The cancer studies that were done in polyps and other
models in humans used about
1,600 milligrams per day. It's really recommended at about
100 to 400 milligrams a day at the most.
And at those super high doses, I think it is also affecting several
other pathways as well.
But that's a whole another story.
Now, I think I stole this slide from Sandy.
It's the adenoma to carcinoma sequence, but we both
stole this from basically Bert Vogelstein, who was the original
person that put this together. So if you look in the colon and go from normal
epithelium to carcinoma, in many
cases, there is an adenoma to carcinoma sequence.
The APC beta-catenin pathway is affected very early.
That beta-catenin pathway does induce COX-2.
There was a nice science paper about that a long time ago.
And then
both Sandy and I worked on this 15-prostaglandin
dehydrogenase. It really goes down dramatically as these
lesions evolve and COX-2
overexpression goes up. Both KRAS is
affected commonly and PI3 kinase in about 20% to
25% of colorectal cancers is mutated, and then
very late, P53 is engaged or lost.
So,
as a clinical fellow at Hopkins, one of the things I learned, and it was
a good lesson about prevention, is if we remove these
lesions from the colon, these people don't die from colorectal
cancer. So, obviously,
you have to do the colonoscopy, snare the polyp, take it out,
look at it under the microscope. But it's clear that if you
intercept this processsurgically in that
case, you can really reduce the risk for colorectal cancer.
Now, this is a slide that Monica Bertagnolli and Ernie Hawk showed at
the 2006 AACR meeting. I can't remember where it
was. But this is looking at all
risks for adenomas, invasive carcinomas, and cancer, and
it's a 48 case control and cohort observational studies that were
published long ago. But this is not just aspirin use.
It's looking at
NSAIDs, which inhibit both COX-1 and COX-2, as well as aspirin.
But I think you can see the trend where there's a significant reduction
in risk on these
long-time users of NSAIDs, including aspirin and non-aspirin NSAIDs.
So you've seen this pathway.
Its 20-carbon arachidonic acid
is converted either with one of
COX-1 or COX-2 to these endoperoxides.
And then there's prostaglandin synthases.
This PGE synthase is the one we've been looking at to create
PGE2.
If 15-prostaglandin dehydrogenase is present, it converts
the PGE2 into an inactive
form that can't bind the PGE receptor.
And then there are at least four PGE2 receptors that this binds
to and has a signal transduction pathway.
The selective inhibitors were designed to inhibit
COX-2 at the concentration that they're
recommended.
But if you go up higher, they can actually inhibit both of these enzymes.
Non-aspirin NSAIDs inhibit both of these enzymes
pretty effectively.
Jorge Captivia and I, when he was at Vanderbilt, did a
study looking at the acetylation of COX-1 and
COX-2 that was made recombinantly in the laboratory.
And aspirin can acetylate both of these enzymes in
that case. And when it acetylates
COX-2, it converts the active site so that it produces
15-RHE instead of
the endoperoxide, which is converted into lipoxins,
which can suppress inflammation.
If you look at the tissue acetylation in vivo,
at low-dose aspirin, only about 10% of COX-2 gets
acetylated. You really have to go up to a higher dose to get full
acetylation of COX-2. So I think at the
cardioprotective dose, you're getting very little acetylation
likely.
So this brings up a whole story about the harms of using something to
prevent cancer that might cause other problems,
especially NSAIDs, COXibs, and aspirin.
So there are always age, dose, and medical history dependent
effects of using these drugs.
Clearly, if you inhibit COX-1, you can lose some of the GI
protective prostaglandins. That causes peptic ulcer disease,
GI toxicity, and then platelets get knocked out, which
can cause more bleeding. COX-2 inhibition, especially at these
very high dosages, causes an imbalance in prostacyclin in the
endothelium, and this is probably what's responsible for the vascular
biology happening
in those patients.
So you get either this peptic ulcer situation, especially
in older patients over the age of 65,
and then you can get a prothrombic state with the inhibition of
COX-2 at high doses, which
can cause stroke and MI, especially in people who have
atherosclerotic disease. They're very susceptible to those side effects.
So Peter Libby did what he called the precision trial that evaluated the
relative toxicity of COX-1 and COX-2 inhibitors, and
he found the same cardiovascular risk present when he
compared celecoxib to ibuprofen versus naproxen
when using the recommended dosage of all of these.
So although these
COX-2 inhibitors got a super bad name when they did these high-dose
studies,
their safety is about equivalent to these over-the-counter
medications.
So just to talk a little bit about targeting the COX-2
pathway and what happens in these preclinical models.
On the left
of the slide here, this is an azoxymethane model where
you gave either a vehicle or celecoxib at an appropriate dose.
And over time, you can see that the animals develop way
fewer adenomas, invasive or non-invasive
adenocarcinomas. And
we didn't even need to have error bars on this because it was so dramatic.
And then there was Mark Taketo in Tokyo, did a
study where he made a new form of APC mutant
mice
there, and then he did the knockout study that Ruth talked about,
where he homogeneously knocked out
COX-2 and saw a significant reduction.
These mice get
several hundred tumors per intestine, and that went
down dramatically with the deletion of the COX-2 gene.
And then the corollary to that is we've been looking at
using celecoxib, which is the proximal part of the
pathway, as opposed to the distal part of the pathway where we can
inhibit the prostaglandin EP4 receptor.
So in this case, again, if we use celecoxib, we get a significant
reduction in both large intestinal and small intestinal polyps
on the top panel. If we use this Japanese
compound, AE3208, it is an
antagonist for the EP4 receptor. Again, we get a very
nice inhibition of both polyp size and
number in both the small and the large intestine.
So clearly, we feel like this is a
PGE2-mediated event because we can block
proximal synthesis or binding to the receptor
for the PGE2 receptor.The other thing
that we played with is using inflammatory stimuli in
this mouse model to see what would happen to the size
and number of adenomas. So we used
this 4% dextran sulfate treatment in the drinking water.
It really causes a massive amount of inflammation in the colon.
And again, we saw a significant increase in size and number
of polyps
in these animals on this regimen. And this has been a helpful
way to look at how you can modulate the
biology or phenotype by overlay with chronic
inflammation.
The other corollary of this is in the ApcMin mice, we were able
to treat these mice with PGE2 by gavage for
eight weeks.
And
in this particular mouse, you don't see an adenoma.
They usually get fewer adenomas in the large intestine than the
small intestine. But on the PGE2-treated mice, we
got very large adenomas, multiple ones that we could
microdissect. And this became a really useful model to
look at the downstream effects of PGE2 on gene
transcription and other things, because we can take these out
by microdissection, isolate cells, RNA,
DNA, or whatever, and look at that.
Again, on the right side, you see that there's a dose-dependent increase in these
adenomas.
We also did a study in collaboration with Gideon Steinbach, who was at MD
Anderson at the time, looking at familial adenomatous
polyposis patients that were in a cohort there.
There were placebo and then two different doses of
celecoxib, and at the highest dose, we saw a
significant reduction, in some cases, a complete
reduction of adenomas.
But only about 20% of these
patients had a really robust response to the drug.
So we think there could be a PI3 kinase connection here
because we didn't look at that, but that could explain what happened.
I see Dr. Chan here. He did a really nice study looking at
the role of COX-2 in expression and in
responders to aspirin, and found that the ones that benefited the
most had an overexpression of COX-2.
And then PI3 kinase mutations, and you saw the
study that Ruth
showed occur in about 15% to 20% of colorectal cancer,
and they seem to be a good predictive marker for
aspirin or NSAID use as well.
So just to quickly review this, PI3 kinase mutations
and COX-2 overexpression frequently coexist.
I don't have time to go through that data.
But tumors with both of these seem to be particularly aggressive and
resistant to some treatments.
There are good epidemiologic studies suggesting that aspirin and
NSAIDs benefit these patients more.
You saw the data that Ruth presented.
And then combining PI3 kinase inhibitors with COX-2 inhibition
seems to yield
an additive or synergistic effect.
So I think this precision prevention or precision treatment is a
great idea. This is the Liao study that
Ruth presented. I'm not going to go through that.
But clearly,
with the mutant PI3 kinase, aspirin is
much more effective.
This is a study looking at survival in patients
treated with adjuvant celecoxib.
So these are PI3 kinase-activated stage III colon cancers.
And on the right, you can see with the PI3
kinase mutation, celecoxib improved
probability of survival compared to the
non-mutant on the left.
And then this Martling paper that just came out in
2025 also showed that low-dose aspirin for PI3 kinase
altered localized colorectal cancer.
And again, you've seen this data, but aspirin improves
the outcome here as well. There are a couple
of prospective trials underway now with celecoxib looking at
mapping the PI3 kinase mutation and then using it as an
adjuvant. It'd be really interesting to see what that happens and how that
works in a prospective trial.
Now, just to finish up here,
just going to review with you some of the
PGE2 effects that we've looked at in a preclinical
situation in the presence and absence of a
selective COX-2 inhibitor. So we found that
if we look for PD-1 positive CD8
T cells or macrophages
in those adenomas that we microdissect and then do flow
cytometry, there's a significant decrease in
PD-1 positivity in the
animals treated with celecoxib, as well as overall T
lymphocytes that go up dramatically following
treatment. And then we also looked at macrophages because there was a
significant reduction
in PD-1 positivity in those macrophages in the treated
animals on the far right.
We saw changes in the immune cell microenvironment very
similar to what we saw with celecoxib when we used this
EP4 receptor inhibitor. And there's
early phase I studies with that now in humans that are looking at
this as
helping to
change the microenvironment so it's more responsive.
So again, PD-1 positivity went down and
total number of T lymphocytes went up, and the PD-1
positive macrophages went down as
wellSo PGE2 can
induce PD-1 expression. We looked in cell culture
initially
at either CD8 T cells or THP-1 cells, which are a
monocyte and macrophage cell. There's a dose response
induction of PD-1.
We looked at RNA and then also PD-1
expression using flow, and again, saw a
significant dose response increase of that.
We also were able to show that PGE2 inhibits CD8 T
cell proliferation and cell killing.
Here, looking at proliferation on this lavender slide,
it goes down over time. And then if we look at the percent of CD8
positive T cells, we could reverse this effect by either using an
anti-PD-1 antibody, an inhibitor of
PI3 kinase or AKT phosphorylation, as well
as an inhibitor of NF-kappa B.
So we tested the killing ability of MT-26
cells, and again, with PGE2, killing went down, but
we could reverse that with all of these
manipulations of these inhibitors in the pathway.
So this is basically what's happening.
PGE2 binds to EP4, activates PI3
kinase AKT, and then ultimately NF-kappa B,
which affects this PD-1 and other aspects of evasion of the
immune system.
We've looked at databases of large numbers
of tumor samples that have expression data, and there does seem to be a
correlation with PD-1 and COX-2 expression,
as well as overall survival, and
that goes down when both of these are at high levels in the
tumor tissue.
So I'm out of time, so I'm going to summarize.
Clearly, PGE2 can affect immune cell biology and immune
competence via upregulation of PD-1.
CD8 T cell cytotoxicity increases dramatically following
inhibition of the pathway. We didn't show the studies today,
but phagocytosis increases also following inhibition of
PGE2. And then I think an area of interest is
targeting this EP4 receptor,
and it's being considered by two or three biotech companies now.
And also, I want to remind you of this exciting cancer prevention
conference coming up in Atlanta on June 3rd and 4th.
These have been very successful, also sponsored
by CRUK. And Sir John Burn, I think, did
the first one in London. So
I'll stop there and take any questions.
Thanks to all the speakers for great talks.
So I guess the themes that have come out of this session kind of focus
in terms of mechanism have sort of settled maybe on
kind of this antiplatelet effect and also this
effect on COX-2.
So Ray, I think
as you've said, aspirin at low dose is a pretty weak COX-2
inhibitor.
Oh, yeah. It's not very good at all.
But it is very good at suppressing prostaglandins at the site-
Right
... in even low doses. So I think if we think about
prostaglandin-dependent mechanisms and antiplatelet mechanisms, I think
there's reasons to think that aspirin may have
maybe dual effects on prostaglandins and maybe platelets as well.
So do you now view celecoxib and the coxibs as being
distinct because there are no antiplatelet effects of the coxibs?
Yeah.
Well, they must be because we do see pretty significant
effects in both humans and in animal models.
And I think hopefully, these
colorectal cancer treatment trials with a neoadjuvant
celecoxib will help with-- Hopefully, they could do some
surrogate markers and other things to try to look at mechanism.
But we haven't looked at the platelet
effect at all. I know Carlo Petrone has been very interested in this,
but it could be a dual effect. I think listening
to all the data at this meeting, I'm going to have to go home and rethink
everything basically.
It's just so interesting that we've always kind of assumed there's overlap in
aspirin and NSAIDs, but it looks like maybe they're-
Yeah, it could be two-
... two distinct preventive agents.
Yeah. That's interesting, Andy.
Great talk, Ray.
You show that lovely slide from Monica Bertagnolli and Ernie Hawk
summarizing all the old studies, and what you didn't point out was that the one
outlier was the Paganini-Hill trial
study of the Leisure World group in California-
Right
... who were the very elderly people.
That's a good point.
More aspirin.
That's a good point, actually.
In fact, we actually had a clue that that might be the case with aspirin because
that population was the one group that didn't see a benefit.
The other, just for your interest, our Heidelberg colleagues
analyzed the biopsies from CUP2 and looked at T cell
invasion or T cell presence in-
Yeah
... normal mucosa. And so again, reinforcing what we've been
hearing today, there was a clear correlation that the people
most likely to get a cancer were the ones who had the fewest T
cells in their mucosa, sort of on guard, in this model.
Right.
The one thing that Paola Patriognani mentioned in her mouse
model was the suggestion that if you take down COX-1,
that it directly, at sort of a molecular level, interacts with the expression
of COX-2.
It does.
So that-
Yeah, we've seen that in some other models tooBecause
PGE2 is an autoregulator of COX-2.
It stimulates COX-2.
Okay. So that could be a direct mechanism for our sort of antiplatelet
effect.
Right.
Okay, I'll stop there.
I'm learning a lot.
Ray, I'm wondering whether, and this is I guess speculative, but
you just showed very elegantly that PGE2 can down-regulate immune
responsive T cells, and there's been other literature that supports
that. But we also just heard that stellate cells play a
role in up-regulating T cell or NK cell
responses in the liver. Do you think that could be due to a different
eicosanoid than PGE2?
I'm not sure. We've done very few metastatic
studies, so it's
hard. I was intrigued by the results.
When we
put
orthotopic cells in the cecum,
if we pre-treat them with PGE2, we see more metastatic
lesions. But that doesn't tell us what's happening in the tissue
environment in that context. So I think that's what needs to be
explored a lot more.
There's also a wonderful dichotomy in the literature that I've always wanted to ask
you about, which is the study by John Potten, right?
Yeah.
Where he gave dimethyl PGE2 IP as opposed to your giving
oral PGE2.
Right.
And he reduced adenomas. And so,
two of the best investigators in the field getting diametric
opposite results. There must be something very special about the route of
administration of the drug, and I'm wondering if you've ever-
No, we haven't tested that. We haven't looked at different routes.
That's a good question.
Hey, Ruth.
Hi. Thank you for a really interesting talk.
Before Vioxx was withdrawn from the market,
those drugs were being evaluated in many different tumor types,
and then that activity ceased.
Yeah.
So my question is, do you think as
oncologists we've missed a potential
anticancer drug that we should be evaluating in different tumor
types?
Yeah. That's a good question. I think there was a lot of
preclinical breast data that looked interesting, and then
there's some subsets of lung cancer that seem to be
responsive. And then esophageal cancer, for example,
there's a lot of COX-2 in that tumor microenvironment.
And initially there were lots of studies, and then everybody sort of backed
off on it after this toxicity.
But that's a good question.
Okay. Are we ready to conclude?
I think we're out of time, and we've had good discussion.
So with that, I'd just like to conclude the session.
Thank you, Ruth and Ray, for fantastic presentations and a great
discussion.